hi I'm Priyanka and I'm Sam Hewitt from
the movie love again and we're here with
BuzzFeed oh we're going to interview
each other oh
[Music]
what was your first impression of me
when we met when did we meet first meet
we we met on Zoom oh yes yes this was
covered days it was during the covert
days this is a covered baby movie my
first impression was you had very good
lighting you were an extremely beautiful
very talented woman in real life it was
very well lit but you were very well
known added HD camera you guys were all
yeah like you could see like half of my
face Sam's camera was all off but I was
in the middle of a press tour at that
time so I was all lit and like soft
focused for the Press tour and my zooms
ended up looking really amazing it was
the lighting very good lighting
you couldn't be an actor anymore what
career would you pursue if you were
guaranteed success
I would be useless at anything else
that's not true I'm a very good rule
follower I guess that's what I'm good
like I can act I don't know what could I
do
I feel like you're like at The Cutting
Edge of everything you're a great
businesswoman because I ventured into
business I would probably get into some
sort of business right I think okay I
would be all about breaking the rules we
should break the rules more I think oh
authorities scares me okay what are the
some surprising or interesting
differences between Bollywood and
Hollywood like today
everyone is on time
Sam was here one minute before call time
right and I am Indian so I'm inevitably
at least five minutes late Indian time
Indian stretchable stretchable time I
see you're right it's called IST and
it's real so next time be be like
considerate to me and just
you know I'm gonna be five minutes later
do you know I
I also you do yeah pretty soon yeah it
just happens that I'm in the same Hotel
so yeah you just walked out it's easy
what are your biggest
biggest I kind of like first I love
First Dates kind of exciting but also
nerve-wracking right yeah for sure it's
difficult isn't it and I suppose you
know going for a meal is always a tough
one it's like what kind of food you
choose because you know if you choose
something messy to eat can be really
difficult like it has to be quite
something quite simple I don't overthink
it
I'm like I love food so I can find
something I will eat anywhere I hate
when you know somebody cracks a joke and
it doesn't land
it's all that awkward silence like
that's that's really tricky and you're
just like how do you move on from that
the thing that just happened that we're
both gonna ignore
all right next one what a hot take you
have
or take a hot take a hot take on
something oh I see I don't understand
this is a sort of American American
International actors we're trying to
don't quite accomplish what the question
is actually I have a controversial
opinion like do fries belong in a in a
book oh I see right got you you know
like uh yeah our characters always have
fries and they put it in a burger like a
huge ketchup fan which I think really
goes down well but I'll have ketchup on
eggs I'll have ketchup on everything I
like ketchup too yeah it's definitely
easy I do hot sauce instead
all right yeah that's not really a
European thing yeah it's definitely
nothing but uh I'm currently working in
Europe and they have mayonnaise on their
fries which I'm sorry I know just can't
get down with it I just that's that's a
hard one it's it's wrong yeah they don't
even give you ketchup no no ketchup I'm
Gonna Fill my bag it's very
controversial yes it is controversial
I'm actually interested about this one
myself you adopted a puppy yeah from
BuzzFeed thank you guys for this
adorable puppy I haven't seen it she's
here actually um I should have brought
well that's the question Diana Chopra
Jonas yeah is the name of the dog yeah
she's adopted both of us what kind of
dog she's a rescue she was a rescue from
North Shore rescue we were doing an
interview with BuzzFeed this is six
years ago she was one of multiple
puppies that they Unleashed on me and I
was supposed to answer questions but she
like was chewing on my Burberry shoes
and then just lay here and fell asleep
and I was like I had to take her home
and then the next day I took her home
and she's here in New York today she's
on this press tour with me she's at home
protecting the baby and hanging out with
my mom I want to know where the puppies
are BuzzFeed come on show me the pair of
Sam's puppies I want puppies too what's
been your favorite Jamie and Claire
scene from Outlander so far this season
or like in life oh wow ever ever
different uh I mean I guess it's there's
love a lot of love in Outlander yeah
um and people love how you love Sam you
know it always goes back to season one
the wedding I think is you know new love
right people falling in love yeah and I
think that's why this movie is so
adorable because it's about two people
finding love again talking of love what
is your love language and just to recap
acts of service
quality time touch gift giving yes
please and words of affirmation love
language is in like how do I receive
love or how do I get it and how do you
give and receive love yeah I think how
I'd do it how I give love is acts of
service I do things for the person I
love
um and how I receive love
no I'm just joking quality time it's
very important for me to have time if
even if you know we're very busy across
the world even taking time out to
FaceTime for half an hour and checking
in with each other or making sure we
update each other through the day and
those kind of things time if you take
time out to be considerate about the
other person I think that's really how I
receive it I'm so shallow you haven't
called called me I haven't called you in
a while and I'm so excited I think mine
would be
probably touch like I want a hug I just
want to hug no that's lovely yeah there
are times I don't want to be touched
well that too yeah what is my name saved
as in your phone uh-oh oh no really yeah
what if you saved me yes
okay good it's not pre there's nothing
else it's just prank you're Sam human oh
you have a full name yeah how many Sams
have you got on your phone Sam McKnight
Sam hewn and Samantha who has saved as
Sam three I only have one prank there is
only one pre I love that the West thinks
that let's not tell them India because
it's a very commonly
it is would you rather live your entire
life this is from the movie with silent
but uncontrollable gas
or
loud uncontrollable sneezes
Island gas you want silent cats on that
note we're gonna clear the room because
I think it's just happened
thank you BuzzFeed I'm thank you thanks
for having us thanks for letting us
interview each other and remember to go
see love again which is out now
thank you